aujourd'hui on est prêt en sandwich en
fait on a de l'instabilité qui remonte
sur la Méditerranée donc il y a encore
des pluies moins que le week-end de
dernier et puis on a un truc qui nous
vient de de Grande-Bretagne c'est une
perturbation qui va être assez active
avec à l'avance s'il vous plaît
ça y est regardez ils sont en train
d'arriver ils descendent à l'instant de
leur appareil les plateaux en ébullition
et on peut dire que la reine Kamiya les
a un peu refroidie avec une descente
d'avion un peu galère c'est vrai que
c'est pas simple il y a du vent faut
tenir son chapeau son sac éviter aussi
que la robe s'envole façon Marilyn
Monroe la séquence a déjà été repéré par
la presse anglaise de mirror estime que
la gêne a été évitée de peu on a vu
aussi dans la délégation Clive de Tom
qui le secrétaire privé du roi et puis
le fameux écuyer qui remporte un succès
absolument terrible auprès des dames de
des deux pays et qui est aussi un très
bon soldat mais on s'attaque du poisson
physique
Barbie mais en tout cas le
sur le réseau X en anglais s'il vous
plaît
plaît traduction de son visage vous
allez visiter
la